determine whether 30 40 fifths and 54
81sts are equivalent fractions well the
easiest way i can think of doing this is
to put both of these fractions into
lowest possible terms and then if
they're the same fraction then they're
equivalent so 30 over 45 30 over 45
what's the largest factor of both 30 and
45 the 1i let's see 15 will go into 30
it'll also go into 45 so this is the
same thing 30 is 2 times 15
and 45 is 3 times 15.
so we can we can divide or both the
numerator and the denominator by 15. so
if we divide both the numerator and the
denominator by 15
what happens well this 15 divided by 15
they cancel out
this 15 divided by 15 cancel out and
we'll just be left with two thirds so 30
40 fifths is the same thing as
two-thirds it's equivalent to two-thirds
two-thirds is in lowest possible terms a
low or simplified form however you want
to think about it now let's think about
let's try to do 54 over 81.
over 81. now let's see
nothing really jumps out at me let's see
9 is divisible into both of these we
could write 54 as being 6 times 9 and 81
is the same thing as 9 times 9. you can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by nine
so we could divide both of them by nine
nine divided by nine is one nine divided
by nine is one so we get this as being
equal to six over nine
and let's see six is the same thing as
2 times 3
9 is the same thing as 3 times 3 we
could just cancel these threes out or
you could imagine this is the same thing
as dividing both the numerator and the
denominator by 3 or multiplying both the
numerator and the denominator by
one-third these are all equivalent i
could write divide by three or multiply
by one-third which let me write divide
by three
let me write divide by three for now
i don't want to assume you know how to
multiply fractions because we're going
to learn that in the future so we're
going to divide by 3 3 divided by 3 is
just 1. 3 divided by 3 is 1 and you're
left with 2 3. so both of these
fractions when you simplify them when
you put them in simplified form both end
up being two-thirds so they are so they
are equivalent fractions